So let's return to our memory management subsystem.
And of course the whole idea of objectization
of the memory management subsystem, or any subsystem
for that matter, is to increase the concurrency for
system services that we're going to offer for
the threads that are executing on the processors.
So in the memory management subsystem, the main
service that we're offering is the page fault service.
And let's say that in this example, there are
two threads T1 and T2. Let's assume that they've
been mapped to the same processor, which means with
the objectization that I described to you they are sharing
a process object. So if T1 incurs a page
fault it's going to through the process object to the
region that corresponds to this particular page fault. And
now let's think about what needs to happen in order
to service this page fault. We might do hierarchical
lockings or for instance if I want to do
some modifications to the region object to indicate that
I'm modifying the data structure that corresponds to this
portion of the address piece, I might say that
well, let's lock the process object. Let's lock the
region object that it corresponds to. Let, let's lock
the FCM object that is backed by this region.
And let's lock the COR object that are actually going to
do the I/O for me. If I do this, and now
let's say the operating system is incurring a page fault
for this second thread P T2. And let's say that this
page fault because it is happening on the same processor,
it shares the same process object, but maybe this page fault
is not for this region, but it is for a
different region, let's say region 2. But if we have locked
the process object in servicing this page fault,
then we cannot get past this process object, because
the lock is held on behalf of servicing
this particular page fault. And therefore, the operating system
cannot process this page fault, even though you
may have multiple cores on the processor. And these
threads are executing on different cores of the same
processor. You don't have the concurrency that you wanted.
So this hierarchical locking kills concurrency and that's a
bad idea. So, what you don't want to do is
do this hierarchical locking. But it seems like, in order
to service this page fault, if I want integrity for
these objects, I want to be able to lock
the critical data structures. But if the path that is
taken by this page fault is different from the path
that is taken by this page fault, why lock this
object in the first place? So we don't have to
lock this object because the path taken by the page
fault service is different from this, and so hierarchical locking
is a bad idea. It kills concurrency. But you do need
integrity of this process object, and in particular if the
reason why we locked this process object is in some sense
to ensure that this process object doesn't go away. How
can it go away? Well, one of the things that can
happen under the covers while page fault service is
happening, there could be a decision to migrate a process
from one processor to another processor. And if that
happens, then the process object may be migrated. And that's
the reason that you have to worry about the
integrity of this process object. When something is happening that
is going to modify something in this process object, you
don't want this process object to go away. That's actually
to do with existence guarantee. So, what we're
going to do is, we're going to associate a
reference count with the object, and rather than
do hierarchical locking, what we're going to do is
put an existence guarantee. Every time this object
is being used, there's a reference count that is
associated with that, and the reference count is
a way of guaranteeing the existence of this object.
So, let's come back to this example again. So if T1
has a page fault, it first go to this, goes to
this process object before it goes to the region object, because
this particular page fault is going to be serviced through this region
object path, but it is not going to hold lock on
this object. What it is going to do is, it is
going to increment a reference count for this object, saying that
this object is in use, please don't get rid of it. And,
subsequently, if this page fault happens, accesses the same
process object, it's also going to increment the reference count.
It is not going to lock this object because
its path is different. It is going through this path
in order to service its page fault, which is
for a completely different page. The whole point of having
a reference count is now, if let's say some
other entity in the operating system, such as a process
migration facility that says, I need to balance the
load on this multiprocessor by moving some process from
this processor to a different one. If it looks
at this process object and it will say well,
I cannot touch this process object, because its reference
count is not zero. Which means that this process
object is currently servicing some requests locally. And that
is the way we can, we can ensure the
existence guarantee for this objects and integrity of
this, of this object. And that can allow
us to get rid of hierarchical locking and
promote concurrency for service activities that can be
provided by the operating system for the same
service, but where there is concurrency that is
possible. In this case page fault service that
can be happening in parallel for independent regions of
the address space touched by the threads that are running on the
same processor, but executing on different cores perhaps of the same processor.